What was so urgent that you had to rush to Star City?
Aliens.
Aliens?
have you lost your minds?
I'm not gonna call you Supergirl.  It's stupid.
How did you get the name Heatwave?
I like to light things on fire.
None of us are going to be alive for long.
Heroes vs Aliens, the 4 Night Crossover event starts with Supergirl
This Monday at 8/7 Central on The CW
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so
new crossover footage let's break it down.
There's also another viral trailer that I'll
explain later in the video but it's a little
weird so I'm going to do this first.
I love this trailer just a little bit better
just because that Heatwave Supergirl moment
I'm not calling you Supergirl could that stupid
why do they call you Heatwave because I like
to light stuff on fire and Supergirl, just
like oh okay and then he torches the Dominators
and what would be there nuts if they did have
nuts, but the thing is is that she also has
heat vision may be will bond over that.
Or maybe she'll bring them a beer or something
like that I feel like it's actually pretty
easy to get in good with Heatwave as long
as you know what speed he moves at, just bring
him a beer.
Don't try to talk to him and leave him alone
but they have a little bit of footage from
each of the different episodes in this like
when Barry comes to Star City and Felicity
is like what are you doing here Barry and
he tries to explain aliens to them see some
more.
This warehouse footage look like to get rid
of throw down this office and can it be a
bunch of big action set pieces like a big
fight scenes the big open spaces shot of their
ship Oliver on their ship firing one of their
weapons.
Maybe this is part of that Arrow episode is
a big twist so I'm curious to see how they
explain him him like that false reality big
group shot.
This is kind of like that Arrow seen from
earlier this year where they did the cool
guy explosion where Oliver walks away without
looking at it.
This is like the version of that on steroids
or open battle looks like they blowup the
Flash Mobile there will be revenge.
How dare you blow up the Flash mobile it almost
looks like vixen citizen stealing Heatwave
are stuck in a prison somewhere, but that
just might be a meeting like the way they
cut it and then them outside assembled at
this airport tarmac makes me think that they
might do a version of like the Capt. America
Civil War airport battle scene one of the
reasons they pick that in Civil War to do
the huge battle scene is because it was really
easy from a filmmaking standpoint he could
have all these characters.
So just like really hard for them to all move
around it for you to be able to see them in
really cool ways you can really do that in
a small contained space.
So naturally like it's even harder to film
an episode of TV because that the move so
much quicker.
So it would make sense that they would have
like a big huge seen in a big open space.
So airports airport hangers like we've seen
in the other trailers is just a easy way to
do that and what about the Hall of Justice
posters that they been releasing so like a
comic book foldout style they been releasing
one sheets for each of the shows.
But when you stack them together.
They all show the Hall of Justice in the background
super friends unite so this might mean will
get the teaser for that somewhere in the episode
but I'm not expecting to actually see full-blown
Hall of Justice in the real world.
I think in the way there teasing this future
Flash storyline on legends but just like wink
at it like oh this is probably going to be
happening in the future of these characters
lives whether or not we actually see it on
the show remains to be seen but never say
never because I we saw the Flash Museum.
When Barry was running back to save his mother
at the end a Flash season 1.
So you never know.
So be prepared for Hall of Justice it would
be pretty crazy if they actually did it.
So just to explain the schedule next week
Supergirl is mostly going to be like a Supergirl
episode like a self-contained story, with
like the end part dedicated to this 4 night
crossover so I will be doing videos for like
each of the episodes for the four night crossover
so I might tune the Supergirl video.
Just a little bit because the be like a lot
of stuff that has Apsley nothing to do with
the four night crossover/will be like the
first official night like the whole episode
will be dedicate of the crossover on Tuesday
that Arrow.
Same thing on Wednesday then Legends of Tomorrow.
Same thing on Thursday so all four episodes
airing next week there's no episode of Arrow
tonight and there is no Legends of Tomorrow
but they did just drop like another found
footage trailer for Legends for the four night
crossover so it's like a little bit different
but all play here than explain what's going
on
so they just meant to be a fun wink at the Dominators have tried to conquer earth before the US Marine Corps went up against
them so that this is classified real it might
be some area 51 twist on it where it was like
this big thing, but because it was so crazy
and aliens, the government Barry did never
told anyone about it but it just a way to
explain that this isn't the first time that
the Dominators have come to earth so it some
point in the four night crossover the learn
about that and learn how they got rid of them.
The first time but it should be a lot of fun
but like we just had that Flash episode that
was super crazy.
So I'm wondering how much of that they're
going to be addressing in episode eight.
Next week I'm guessing that that the four
night crossover story is going to be relatively
self-contained.
But there are like of few things that will
bleed into the rest of the season on each
of the shows like the future Flash storyline
on legends of tomorrow Barry Allen from the
distant future leaves this secret message
for the legends are really is for rip hunter
in the legends just here it implies that something
really terrible is going to be happening to
him which probably has something to do with
this avatar plot line.
They did tease that Barry will be learning
things about his future, which is zero-sum
like Martin Stein is going to confront Barry
with some of this information and we know
that Supergirl is gonna be coming back for
another crossover on the Flash in the second
half of the season is just going to be like
a Supergirl Flash episode so it won't it will
be like Arrow or legends or anything like
that so I'm wondering if the gonna tease how
that might happen to each of the shows this
season has done like a slightly better job
of threading plot lines along so that when
they get paid off.
It's a much bigger deal because they been
seating at the whole time.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There's a new round of the DC giveaway that's
going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video what's going
to happen next is I'll post Spider-Man Homecoming
and then there was like a Kevin Feige super
post where he went on and on about Marvel
vs DC the state of the comic book filmmaking
industry and why it is that they'll probably
not be able to make a deal with Fox for the
X-Men characters so those will be my next
videos to post Spider-Man will probably be
next because it was a really cool Spider-Man
stuff so get hype it can be really fun and
happy Thanksgiving everybody that celebrates
Thanksgiving this week what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for my
killer Frost video from last night and you
can click here for my Godspeed versus Savitar
video.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!